let me ask you about this so I have a
well for various reasons uh
my wife is is not drinking for the next
okay nine months
and I went to Vegas with my buddies last
weekend okay we all went me my wife and
their my buddies and their wives so it
was I had my spiritual hazmat suit on me
uh you can't get in trouble that way but
you know I I I I decided after this trip
that I am done with her to with with uh
with the drinking too
and I got to admit the last it's been
like four days and I'm not a heavy
drinker but I do like to have a drink
you know once uh you know once a night
like I like a sugar-free Red Bull vodka
around 4 30 maybe another one around 6
30. all right and then I'm usually done
depending on a couple more shots but I
gotta say that it's you know the these
last couple of days
I've really had this urge to and I was
like I don't have a problem maybe I do
have a problem you know you don't have
to be a fall down drunk I don't think to
to to have a have an issue and I feel
like maybe I do and and I feel like that
alone will enhance my life people that I
know like you
and are you yeah
everybody that I know that's done it Dax
is another one Dax is a good buddy of
mine
uh I played golf with Jason Bateman at
the 18t this guy's lives have just like
elevated from it maybe there's something
to that here's the thing
any other disease
the best you can hope for is to get back
to as healthy as you were before you got
sick yeah but for us when we treat our
disease we become a better version of
ourselves than we ever were before yeah
it's crazy yeah I see that a lot and
it's just kind of done them and reads
them because I don't have a drinking
problem and I'm not sure I'm a maybe I
am uh
there's clearly something there that I
feel like I want to explore yeah what
the potential is just taking it out
there's different categories of uh of
drinkers there's uh what's the first one
problem Drinker and
um this is the the person who recognizes
they have a problem and and are able to
moderate or stop all together
I don't remember and then uh and then
what alcoholic by depth and by
definition means that that you you want
to stop you just can't yeah now you've
got this powerlessness yeah to stop and
um I think it's a little bit as a rule
of thumb
uh if nobody who's not an alcoholic ever
wonders if they're an alcoholic
that could be a rule of thumb mine was
like I was more of like trying to stop
and not and then but I was I was more
resentful of myself for like operating
at like 60 my potential yeah and I felt
like that's where I'm at yeah honestly
yeah on the other hand though like for
example if if you go on any kind of a
diet you know like oh I'm gonna like eat
less yeah like as soon as you decide
you're on a diet all you can think about
is food yeah yeah so the very Act of of
seeking to quit like just makes you
obsessed with it yeah that that uh calls
to mind the saying what you resist will
persist yeah so if you're trying to
resist it then um then that makes it
more difficult yeah and I think that for
us we call it consider it rather than
resisting it we surrender yeah yeah you
know we uh surrendered and we admit
defeat yeah but has it has nothing to do
with the alcohol or whatever the vice is
it's like what are you covering up and
so like the the very fact of like not
medicating or numbing like the things
that come up yeah are the things that
you have to deal with and then once you
deal with them your life gets better
yeah it's not like oh I quit drinking my
life gets better it's like things are
going to come up in your head where like
maybe you're shoving down you're
probably more able to deal with them
yeah but you don't even know what's
coming up because you're like oh it's I
don't have drink yeah and then exactly
cool but then as it comes up you're like
oh [__] what is that and then you know
it might be like a fear of directing or
whatever the next it's like then what
you're like oh wait what is that then
you're like it's plaguing me and you
start talking about it and then you talk
to somebody and actually has something
to do with something else that you fix
that's why your life gets because the
ripple effect off that root cause is
what makes it better it's like the thing
on the desk the balls that are hanging
like you pull back one ball yeah and
then you let it go but it's actually
some like the fourth ball down that pops
up yeah you know right like what's
kicking off isn't the actual issue it's
something underneath yeah
I always wish I like you know this
alcoholic I am is like I always wish
that I worked the steps of the 12-step
program before I quit drinking so like
my life could have gotten better and I
could have still drank yeah I was always
like why did I do this like when I was
like 18 because then I could still drink
and have a good but like yeah that's not
yeah mine is not mine's never been the
guy who wakes up the morning has to
continue right but it is something that
you know I've become accustomed to
having a drink
and it's and I've realized recently that
it's holding me back you know and it's
and it's it's numbing me out to a point
where I'm not as present as I need to be
or I'm not as creative as I could be
and and you know I'll be a bet I'm
hoping because of this and dealing with
the stuff that will come up and it does
it is coming up now because
the last few nights I'm like this is
normally when I go but what I've done is
I've just gone and done yoga instead or
I've gone and worked out instead so I'm
trying to do things to replace that
three hour gap where I would normally be
craving a yeah they say like in the
first couple weeks when you quit
drinking it and you have that urge have
a piece of chocolate because the sugar
is the same sugar that your body's
craving that's why chew on some
chocolate you've heard that too yeah
I've heard that at AAA meetings they
have a lot of cookies and cake around
for that reason huh yeah it's okay you
know so to your point
if I do or you're okay can't remember
whose point now are you drunk yeah maybe
I'm drunk
the uh you know I haven't I haven't been
like I'm done you know because I I know
that if the more I resist it the more
it'll persist
so it's like
I'm just gonna try this till January
and hopefully by that time I'll be
past it and I'll have enough distance
between me and it that I won't need it
I'm hoping I'm hoping that I get to a
place you know the idea of never having
one again is a little bit freaky to me
but just taking a break from it for a
while and doing the work to support it I
think will help and they uh that's
something that helped me and said if you
imagined you know all of the laundry
that you know for the rest of your life
it'd be yeah it has a lot of laundry but
we just do one load at a time
yeah you drink during the buddy games oh
yeah so you probably think it had like
[__] well I'm not gonna be able to drink
at that Buddy game yeah yeah it's true I
mean it's like you know the lake this I
spent a lot of time at my Lake cabin and
there's always a Busch Light yeah for
sure it sounds like but like it it
sounds like the scariest situation to me
because I consider myself so lucky that
it got as bad as it did that I just had
to address it yeah you know what like
the way that I was could not continue it
just needed to be addressed it was
urgent and as a result because I
addressed it here I've like you know
I've been able to free up so much time
and get super focused and make less
mistakes and yeah what do you think you
would have addressed it if they if
Knoxville and them didn't come and I
remember that I was out of gas at the
end of The Run what are you trying to
like weren't you trying to like throw
yourself off a building first thing it
was it was all bad what scares me is the
idea of it of kind of having alcoholism
just a little bit just enough to
interfere with
you know like uh your life interfere
with your relationships slow you down
like kind of walking in quicksand a
little bit yeah you know but it's not so
bad that it needs to be addressed so it
just goes on and on and on I feel like I
know people who have just had years kind
of slipped through their fingers and
then the years turn into decades and the
next thing I get old and you're thinking
man like yeah like uh I didn't operate
at my Highest Potential yeah yeah it
took me a while to quit drinking because
I was like oh there's a wedding in two
weeks yeah where there's a friend going
away so but there's always something
yeah then again I think it's worth
noting that you're evidently doing
pretty well you know I think that well
it's relative because he's probably like
what's my potential if I'm doing this
well
yeah maybe I mean I I am able to to
accomplish things but I'm not operating
as as efficiently as I should be I could
be you feel like you're eating soup with
a fork yeah kind of I'm still getting
full I'm still doing I'm still like I'm
still getting stuff done but not as
clear-headed as I need to be you know
I'm a little bit slow in the morning or
I'm you know not as present as I should
be as a father which really yeah that
bums me out I'm a good dad but I feel
like it could be a really good dad if I
were how old you're a kid now nine oh
okay you know that's uh yeah I mean that
that's that's important yeah
um in uh our beverage program the
literature is pretty clear that um you
know if if uh you think you have a
problem like you know but this is how it
works but but you know if you're not
sure then yeah go give it another try
you know but if you find yourself going
around the loop where you you don't want
to drink and you died I went and did it
you know like and and then you're going
then maybe think about like actually
um
to following the path laid out in the
book of the beverage program yeah yeah
yes you probably didn't see this
interview going this direction whatever
it's all good because it seems to happen
quite a bit with us I think yeah we love
it like I'm pretty careful about
um just like if it comes up organically
I'm happy to talk about it but I don't
like we have the flag I don't lead with
it it's never my primary purpose I think
between us we have 30 years here right
15 10 5 5 yeah 30 yeah 5 10 15. you're
15 years cleaning yeah wow damn and it's
crazy huh that is nuts next thing you
know you're the same age as old people
yeah
that's the truth that's
liquiddeath.com
Stevo for 20 off of your first order of
apparel and if you haven't seen liquid
death apparel it's epic it's hilarious
it's epic the social media for this
company is like I think they're the most
followed beverage drink like I don't
know what I mean dude they're killing it
so support liquid death by going to
liquiddeath.com Stevo buying the tea on
Amazon your local retailers to support
this company man
yeah dude